PETE: WNBA PLAYER BRITTNEY
GRINER BACK ON U.S. SOIL AND
UNDERGOING EXTENSIVE MEDICAL
EVALUATIONS AFTER BEING
IMPRISONED IN RUSSIA FOR NEARLY
A YEAR.
WILL: IT COPS AS A COST WITH THE
RUSSIAN ARMS DEALER KNOWN AS
MERCHANT OF DEATH AND KNOWN FOR
CONSPIRING TO KILL MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AND PROVIDING WEAPONS
TO TERRORISTS.
>> VIKTOR BOUT IN MY EYES IS ONE
OF THE MOST DANGEROUS MEN ON THE
FACE OF THE EARTH.
>> ON THE FACE OF THE EARTH?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT.
HE'S ARMING NOT ONLY DESIGNATED
TERRORIST GROUPS, INSURGENT
GROUPS BUT ALSO ARMING VERY
POWERFUL DRUG TRAFFICKING
CARTELS AROUND THE GLOBE.
LISA: RETIRED MARINE BOND
TECHNICIAN AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOEY JONES WITH
RETIRED NAVY SEAL OFFICER AND
COMMANDER JOCKO.
HEY, GUYS.
REPORTER: GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
SO, JOCKO, YOU SAW THAT
BASICALLY WE HAVE TRADED AN ARMS
DEALER, SOMEONE CALLED THE
MERCHANT OF DEATH FOR BRITTNEY
GRINER TO GET BACK HOME AND YOU
WERE ON A TEAM THAT MIGHT HAVE
TO GO GET SOMEONE IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT IT?
>> HAPPY THERE'S AN AMERICAN
BACK ON AMERICAN SOIL BUT IT
MAKES ME WORRIED ABOUT THE WAY
THE WORLD PERCEIVES AMERICANS
AND RUNNING AROUND
DAY, ARMY NAVY AND WE WANT TO
GET YOUR OPINION ON THAT SUBJECT
TODAY.
NAVY BEAT ARMY LAST YEAR.
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS JOCKO
GOING TO BEAT PETE FOR SAYING
THE NAVY, PHYSICALLY NOT
THEORETICALLY BUT IS JOCKO GOING
TO BEAT PETE FOR SAYING THE
MARINES ARE THE MEN OF THE NAVY.
>> LOOK, I WORK DIRECTLY WITH
THE ARMY A LOT AND ACTUALLY
SPECIFICALLY THE FIRST ARMY
DIVISION WEARING THAT UNIFORM
TODAY IN MEMORY OF THEM AND SO
I'M DEFINITELY EXCITED TO SEE
THE GAME AND MATTER OF FACT, MY
LAST DEPLOYMENT THEY CALLED MY
UNIT ARMY SEALS SO AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED TODAY, AMERICA WINS.
WILL: I'VE SEEN JOCKO AND HE
REFUSES TO ENGAGE IN THE BRANCH
RIVALRY STUFF BUT YOU LAUNCHED
THE NUKE, HE DIDN'T.
I WONDER IF HE'LL SILENTLY
RESPOND.
WILL: HE'S A MAN WITH A LOT MORE
RESTRAINT AND DISCIPLINE.
PETE: HE'LL GET MY SILENTLY, NOT
ON TV.
LISA: JOCKO, WHAT'S YOUR
PREDICTION OF THE DAME?
>> NOT SURE OF THE GAME AND
PREDICT PETE MIGHT RUN INTO
TROUBLE IN THE FUTURE.
WILL: THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING
FOR.
LISA: THAT'S THE RESPONSE WE
WANTED.
WELL DONE. DONE.
REPORTER: PETE, YOU PUT ME RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE BRINGING OCCUPY
THE MARINE CORP..
WILL: JOEY, IT'S PETE THAT'S
THROWING SAILORS URN THE BUS --
UNDER THE BUS.
REPORTER: THE ARMY IS HONORING
THE UNIT WITH THE UNIFORMS AND
NAVY IS HONORING 54 NASA
ASTRONAUTS THAT CAME OUT OF THE
NAVY MORE THAN ANY OTHER SERVICE
AND ON THE ARMY UNIFORM, YOU SEE
THE WORD OLD IRON SIDE AND
THAT'S THE U.S. S CONSTITUTION
AND WE'RE LOVING EVERYBODY
TODAY.
PETE: DID MORE ASTRONAUTS COME
FROM THE NAVY THAN THE AIR
FORCE?
REPORTER: YES, 100%, YES.
PETE: I HAD TO IDEA.
WHY IS THAT?
EITHER KNOW WHY THAT WOULD BE
THE CASE?
NAVY TO SPACE?
REPORTER: PILOTS.
PILOTS.
PILOT PROGRAM.
TOP GUN.
PETE: AIR FORCE HAS PILOTS TOO
TO YOUR POINT.
WILL: ALL RIGHT, WE'RE GOING OFF
THE RAIL